a given City had a population of 100,000
in the year 2000 by year 2005 this
population had grown to
115,000 city planners estimate a
geometric growth rate until 2012 the
city's goal is to not increase their net
water usage by how many gallons would
they need to reduce their usage in 2012
in order to have the same water use as
in 2005 assume the 2005 water use is 160
Gall per capita day so the keywords in
this problem related to population
growth are geometric growth
rate we can search for this in our
reference manual taking us to chapter 6
section 6.1.6 point2 to a section called
log growth equals exponential growth
equals geometric growth a long title but
it does give you the direct equation
that you'll need so the first thing
we're going to do is find our growth
rate this equation is given as
follows Ln to the P
subt equals Ln to the P Sub 0 plus K *
delta
T where in this case PT is population at
time t p Sub 0 is population at Time
Zero K is our growth rate and delta T is
the elapsed time in years relative to
zero so we can begin to fill this
equation out and find our growth
rate so p subt is going to be our
population at the Year
2005 and P Sub 0 is going to be our
population
in the year
2000 we are solving for K since our
first goal is to find the geometric
growth rate and we know that t is going
to be the difference in years let's call
it year 1 to year
zero so if we use our calculators to get
Ln of
115,000 we get just about
11.65 and if we do the same thing here
we get just about
11.51 and then this gives us K *
5 calculating this out we get a k of
just about
0.028 so that is our growth
rate now let's go to step two so we
found what the growth rate is which
means we can find our population in
2012 so again we can use our same
exponential growth equation so we can
write this out again as Ln P subt equal
Ln P Sub 0 plus K * delta T but in this
case Ln of p subt is going to be our
unknown since that's what we're
calculating for Ln of P subz the new
year that we want is going to be 2005 so
we're going to place 115,000 in this
variable and then K we can fill in of
0.028 and delta T is going to
be 2012us 205 the years corresponding to
the populations that we
have and if we calculate this out Ln of
P subt equals 11.65 we we could just use
the same number from over here if we
want and not calculate it again
plus
0 2 is what I'm going to estimate that
number out to
[Music]
be so Ln of P subt equals just
about
11.85 now if you remember your Calculus
raising anything with an Ln by base e
will convert
this to
one
so this goes
away if we add e to both
sides leaving us with a number we can
calculate out because we can calculate
this in our calculator as well and get
139 91
so this is our new population in
2012 so step three now that we know our
new
population we can determine how much the
water use needs to be reduced in order
to not change from 2005 to
2012 so the problem gives us our current
water use of 160 gallons per capita
day and from here we can just figure out
the difference in population as a
percent and our units are still gallon
per capita day so this is what the new
water use would have to be in order for
it to remain unchanged from the previous
year but the question asks us by how
many gallons would they need to reduce
their usage so instead of falling for
this trick over here we simply subtract
the number we calculated here
from
160 and we'll get 28.5
gallons per capita day which our closest
answer over here is 30 and that's all it
takes to solve this problem this is
pretty much just an equation-based
problem that is given to you directly
from the manual and all we need to do is
first find the growth
rate Second Use that growth rate to find
the increase in
population and then third find the
reduction in water use required to
maintain the same total water use for
the new population as it originally was
for the old
population as long as you can remember a
a little bit of calculus such as e to
the Ln and you know how to plug these in
on your calculator which there should be
a button for Ln and there should be a
button for E you should be fine and
that's
it